Terry McCauley an NBC Sunday Night
Football rules analyst and a former NFL
referee kind enough to join us give us
his thoughts on the new rule change to
replay Terry thanks for joining us are
you thumbs up thumbs down with adding
more replay I got to tell you I'm with
you Dan and I'm pretty much thumbs down
and you know there's several reasons and
it's philosophically from an officiating
standpoint I really believe these types
of calls need to be made in real time on
the field and you leave it there I get
that that's probably old school now and
they've moved on from that but on a more
real level
I too am concerned about stoppages I
know we have outside of two minutes the
coaches challenge that will limit that
but how many more of them are they going
to use now that this is part of the
review process you know are we going to
get to two and three by each coach every
single game and then you get under two
minutes and and I was listening to you
and you you nailed it how many of these
contested passes in the two-minute drill
are going to need to be stocked to see
if the defender was two frames early
when he hit the receiver take me through
the process of in the final two minutes
who is going to tell you if you're on
the field and a call is missed how will
you find out that this needs to be or
will be reviewed if you're the head
official the replay official is going to
buzz down I say buzz down that's the old
Pater said he's got he's gonna radio
down and tell the officials tell the
referee to stop the game and the play is
under review just like any other
incomplete pass or any other stepped out
of bounds or touchdown whatever there
the replay official is going to stop the
game under two minutes or an overtime to
review whether it was pass interference
or not is there anything positive in
this well sure I mean you just like the
former any other replay process you
don't ever want to have a call that
costs the team
I understand the need to get those right
and this is you know that this is going
to hopefully fix those but when you
start looking at at every play is there
pass interference or not you know I
heard Mike my good friend Mike Florio
Turk talked earlier about clear and
obvious egregious yeah III don't see
that as being the case here and and we
have a perfect example in the Super Bowl
just before the game clinching
interception by New England there was a
pass to Brandon cooks in the end zone
and real time nobody thinks this is pass
interference
not even a not even a blip of a thought
well then they go to slow-motion replay
and Tony Romo accurately and correctly
says oh there's a little arm grab there
just before the ball gets there well is
that a foul or not is you know in real
time it wasn't it's never going to be
called in real time yeah but my
understanding is the committee looked at
that and that is that will be called you
see that that is enough to be called
pass interference by replay do you think
the NFL talked to officials before they
made this change
I I think they had some conversations as
the process was developing but but then
you got to you got to the meeting
yesterday and it all seemed to happen
based on on coaches I think they they
pushed it through it's what they wanted
and and the owners you know the owners
fell in line so I don't think there was
this thorough thought process once the
momentum got started yesterday I I know
you listened to the show so you know how
I feel about these all-star crews when
we get to the playoffs I don't want that
because I want you with your family with
the group that you worked with every
single week therefore egos don't get in
the way somebody's going to say to you
hey Terry I think I think we missed this
one I think you missed that one I don't
know why the other officials didn't
weigh in because they could see that
play you could hear that play that was
helmet-to-helmet and pass interference
why didn't somebody say hold on here
huddle up
I think we got a problem here because
three officials were looking at that in
real-time and they believe there wasn't
a foul they and and I think there's a
systemic problem there because and I
think it developed throughout the
playoffs that it felt like officials
were looking for reasons not to throw a
flag and on that play they felt it was
bangbang you know they were looking at
the contact whether it was dpi or not I
you know the helmet contact I think was
it was was just something that was
happening to be part of it yeah but they
they felt in real-time that based on
their guidance from their superiors but
that was a bang-bang play it was too
close to call and it was not a foul yeah
and by the way that that has been a
philosophy for years bangbang plays
don't frame-by-frame it I believe that
goes away now with replay he's either
early or he's not early he's a Terry
McCauley NBC Sunday Night Football rules
analyst former NFL official I was also
wondering this we had JJ Watt on in the
first hour and I said you know we're
looking at replay and everything is to
help off
it feels like that here we are with the
challenge and you can overturn Sun
overturn a call or there was no call
we're gonna you know make the call
D Ford with a hit on Tom Brady wouldn't
have been reviewable I'm guessing there
but will it will it now no and that was
one of the proposals that and this is
probably the most surprising thing of
all of this damn is that I felt they
were going to put players safety fouls
into this category of reviewable place
first because I and I'm even for that I
think player safety cells are a separate
category over anything else that we look
at in football I can live with more
stoppages to make sure we get player
safety fouls correct but that was not
approved they went right to the DPI OPI
thing and it just surprised me I mean
player safety has been such a huge part
of the NFL culture protecting that over
the last few years I thought that was a
shoo-in to be honest with you what role
does gambling play in this new rule or
the I guess this being brought out and
more replay from an officiating
standpoint none at all
I I just it just has no effect on
anything officials ever do we it's it's
completely in our mind you know all the
officials I ever known we don't even
talk it's not even discussed it's it's
not even part of the equation we're just
trying to go out and do our job but as
far as from the NFL perspective well
they have it they have a different
viewpoint and I think they are looking
at it from a long-term they're doing
everything to make sure they believe
they're doing everything they should
make sure that that there isn't they
aren't subject to that accusation
did you guys ever it's hard not to know
this the point spreads on games that you
were doing I I did I can't ever remember
even paying attention to it I mean you
knew if it was a mismatch you know if
you know if you were playing New England
against Arizona or whatever they were a
mismatch but as far as point spreads
that's that was that was always
irrelevant Terry
great to catch up with you again I hope
you're enjoying the offseason there and
we'll look forward to Sunday Night
Football I am thanks very much Dan
that's so Terry McAuley for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]